Here I see
that
David Wood's
cult group, they're all in New York. I
just want to mention this. Oh my
goodness.
I cannot believe this.
This is Islam.
But what they're doing in New York is
antagonizing the Muslims who took over
Times Square. So we're going to wait for
this guy,
this Rogers fanboy.
Oh my goodness.
I don't know if I don't get it. Is that
sure not sure which is more disturbing.
One, Dr. Mooy praying for North Korea to
nuke a country with 1.8 million Muslims
just to kill some Jews. Damn.
Two, thousands of people liking his
post. Three, his followers being stupid
enough to think North Korea would start
nuclear war with Israel.
My goodness.
So, they're at Times Square. I guess
they let them pray in Times Square
during Ramadan.
And a fight almost broke out.
And the cult is there. David Wood's
click. May the Lord Jesus crush and
destroy this click. Save them from
idolatry. Save David from himself. Save
me from myself, that we love Jesus
Christ. Now, there they go right here.
Now, if Worship that crap and free
We're going to go into the debate. I'm
just waiting for this guy. If you don't
understand why they're doing this,
there is Hadith where Muhammad said,
"Nothing nullifies your prayer except a
woman and a dog."
So, here's Hatun in New York with a dog.
And there is Anthony, part of the cult
movement.
He's no better than them. He's actually
a fake.
And I have no respect for them. And I
pray that God will make me a man of
integrity and speak the truth even if it
costs me.
And may I not be fake and the Lord
remove the beams in our in our eyes.
Now, listen, guys. I'm going to say
something.
I hate Islam and I hate Muhammad as much
as I hate Satan.
Yeah, no, he's he's a fake, brother.
I tried to be nice and good, but we got
to call it what it is. He's a cult
leader. He's a fake. He's overrated,
just like Anthony Rogers.
Now, I hate Islam, guys. I really do.
But, I do not understand. Do you think
they're doing this
out of love for Christ and spreading the
gospel?
Is Now, I'm being honest. Now, I hate
Islam.
I hate Muhammad as much as I hate Satan.
But, to come before them with a dog,
with a woman, knowing you're going to
antagonize them.
Is this really
I don't know. Maybe I'm wrong. I'm
trying I'm not trying to be pious. I'm
just trying to figure it out. Is this
what Christ called us to do?
Or like this clown, Anthony, quoting
Revelation 3:9, saying, "They couldn't
wait for the day of judgment where the
synagogue of Satan would bow to us.
They're bowing to us now."
Wrenching Revelation 3:9 out of context
to mock the Muslims. Now, this is evil.
For them to take over Times Square with
the permission of New York, that's
wicked. But, you know what's sad?
The cops took the side of the Muslims.
What do I mean?
We're waiting I'm waiting for this clown
to show up.
Here, this is Wayne.
Here, almost caused a fight.
HEY, ARE YOU THAT INTIMIDATED?
YO, ARE YOU THAT INTIMIDATED?
ARE YOU THAT INTIMIDATED? YOU GOT TO SAY
SOMETHING?
WHAT YOU DOING?
WHY YOU STEP UP LIKE THAT?
YOU WANT TO DO SOMETHING?
WHAT ARE YOU GETTING ALL FRISKY FOR?
YEAH, DON'T STEP UP TO ME LIKE THAT.
DON'T STEP UP [laughter] TO ME LIKE
THAT.
OR YOU'RE GOING TO GET HURT. YEAH, DON'T
STEP UP TO ME LIKE THAT. YOU WANT TO GET
HURT, LITTLE BOY?
YOU GETTING IN THE RING. YOU GETTING IN
NOW EXPLAIN WHY I'M SAYING IF this is
right.
Do unto others as you'd have them do
unto you, right?
I don't want Muslims to come to my
event.
I don't want Muslims to come
outside of my church.
I don't want Muslims to desecrate the
Bible. I don't cuz I love the Bible. I
love the word of the Lord Jesus Christ.
I love the church.
I don't want them to come and mock.
Right?
I'm not trying to be pious. I'm just
trying to understand. Maybe you guys can
help me.
May I never get involved in these
things. If I have done in past, God
forgive me.
All right, so
watch how the policeman say, "They're
known for doing this." Is this a
positive testimony?
And I thought Anthony's a minister of
the gospel.
No, I'm being honest. I'm not trying to
be pious. I'm not. May God save me from
my own wickedness and forgive me. I
really want to know, is this
really glorifying Jesus Christ? Is her
tattoo really glorifying Jesus Christ?
Coming with a dog in front of them
when she knows
she's going to incite a reaction?
Does she live for this? Causing riots
and thinking that she's doing Jesus
Christ a favor? And this clown who
claims to be a minister and he's a man
of integrity still associating with
folks, one of whom
is in an adulterous relationship and
he's part of these Orthodox church,
which he thinks is a false church
preaching false gospel?
Is Are they really
servants of the Lord?
Look at his reaction. Watch what the cop
says. Hey, ARE YOU THAT INTIMIDATED?
YO, are you that intimidated?
ARE YOU THAT INTIMIDATED? YOU GOT TO SAY
SOMETHING?
WHAT YOU DOING?
NO, MAN. WHY DID YOU STEP UP LIKE THAT?
YOU WANT TO DO SOMETHING?
YEAH, DON'T STEP UP TO ME LIKE THAT.
DON'T STEP UP TO ME LIKE THAT.
>> [laughter]
>> OR YOU'RE GOING TO GET HURT. YEAH, DON'T
STEP UP TO ME LIKE THAT. YOU ARE GOING
TO GET HURT, LITTLE BOY.
>> [laughter]
>> YOU'RE GOING TO GET IT, LITTLE BOY. I'LL
SEE YOU RING AND HE'S FLEXING.
NOW, watch what the cop's going to say.
Listen. Listen to the cop.
Now, it is disgusting and tragic that
the Muslims have taken over Times
Square, but
if this is something the city gave them
permission to do,
then that means the Christians can also
go to the city and ask that Christians
can have an event in Times Square. And
if they say yes, then it's fair, right?
Fair is fair.
Freedom of assembly, freedom of
religion, religious expression.
So,
obviously, they asked the city for
permission to come on Times Square,
rent it out to pray and speak. That
means Christians can do that. So, then
do the same thing.
Go get
permission from the city, have a huge
Christian event in Times Square, bring
in your top apologists, and let them
preach the gospel of Jesus Christ, and
sing praises to the Lord. But,
watch what the cop's going to say about
the Christian. Listen. Look at IT THERE,
WITNESS.
>> THE PROBLEM.
AS MUCH as I hate Muhammad, I hate him
as much as Satan, and as much as I hate
Muslim prayers and the Quran,
we are stuck in a catch-22.
If the same
freedoms we enjoy and if we don't want
them taken away from us, freedom of
assembly, freedom of religious
expression,
then we cannot then
stop the Muslims from taking advantage
of those laws without then affecting our
freedom to assemble. You see how You see
how it works? If we then complain,
you can't let Muslims do this,
and we want them to forbid them, then
they're going to forbid all religious
groups.
That means it'll hinder us from
assembling. You see we're in a bad
position, right?
Right?
You know how much I hate the fact that
Muslims are out there praying on Times
Square and Allahu Akbar cuz this is a
declaration that eventually they're
going to take over America.
But wait, freedom of assembly, freedom
of religious expression.
Now, if New York discriminates against
Christians, bring a lawsuit. That's what
you should do.
Fair is fair.
Now, watch what the cop says to him.
Look, the cop is on the side of the
Muslims. Look.
Their whole goal is to make you
go wild. All right? Don't give them the
satisfaction. Don't give them the
satisfaction to make you
Their whole goal is to make you go wild.
All right? Don't give them the
satisfaction. Don't give them the
satisfaction, please. All right? All
right? You're here for a prayer. Do what
you need to do. All right? But they're
They're professionals. They know how to
hook people. So, do me a favor
and take the class. Be calm. is very
upsetting. I I understand, but we're
here to help you guys out.
No one
We're here to help you guys out. Don't
you see what an embarrassment?
The Christians are portrayed as the
enemies,
as the antagonists,
as
the the devils.
And we are here to help you out. What an
embarrassment.
That is the police talking almost I'm
saying, they know how to beat you in.
Don't fall for it.
We don't We're trying to keep the peace
here, all right?
>> [laughter]
>> Hey, are you there? only here?
I I'm Again, I don't know. Again, I'm
not trying to be pious. I'm not. I
deserve help. Not better than David Wood
or Anthony.
What I'm just trying to understand,
we're going to go into the culture.
We're waiting for that guy who was
manifesting. Going to eclipse.
I really I want to understand. I I never
liked the idea of going before mosques,
when I used to join George Zaid,
ministering Muslims, be outside mosque
passing out Bibles. Why?
Because I don't want Muslims outside the
church,
outside any Evangelical Trinitarian
outside the Catholic church, outside the
Orthodox church, passing out Qurans and
pamphlets on why Islam is true,
Christianity is false. I don't want
that.
So, why am I doing it to them?
Number one. Number two.
I don't want Muslims to come and harass
and antagonize Christians in their
festivals and their assembly.
They want to come listen, come listen.
They want to come and watch, come watch.
But to do something that they know would
antagonize us,
I don't like that.
So, should I then
do that to them?
Hot to touch brings a dog, she's in
front of the And I even played the
Hadith by the way, the Hadith.
They did it deliberately and they're
revelling in it. Really, I don't know.
This is the guy by the way.
Wayne, the guy who Malik has been
exposing.
They're revelling in it. I don't know.
Is it I Maybe I'm wrong. I'm not trying
to be fake here. I'm trying to
understand honestly.
Nonetheless,
let's get into the topic because and
we're waiting for the guy who was
barking and manifesting
because he's a man worshipper.